hey this is going to bring great
pleasure to many in our audience it's
time to say bye-bye to me David Pakman
is leaving the David Pakman show just
for four shows next week next week we're
going to be having guest host Monday
through Thursday and then we are sort of
wrapping the Memorial Day holiday to
include next Friday so that staff gets
an additional day off in addition to the
federal holiday so we're gonna be having
guest hosts for the first part of next
week Ben Dixon will be splitting guest
hosting duties with Ferren cousins from
Ring of Fire I'm gonna be combining my
much overdue vacation which I skipped
people may not know this I I'm our turd
myself so that everybody else could get
a vacation early in 2019 and I skipped
mine and I am now going to be taking a
few days off combining it with a trip to
a wedding and sort of a work trip and
then we'll have the Memorial Day holiday
so people who want me kicked off of my
own show which shockingly is a bigger
number than you might imagine
I effectively am being kicked off of my
own show for all of next week and you'll
have a week break although I never
really understood if you dislike me that
much if you dislike this program that
much it seems like you could just watch
a different show or listen to a
different podcast or just if you listen
on the radio tune to something else but
it seems like for a lot of people that's
not a possibility they want to be
listening to this show they just want
someone else hosting it which doesn't
really make sense when it's the david
pakman show I don't know but I will be
back please be nice to Ferran and to Ben
they're gonna do a really really great
job they're gonna do the regular show
they're gonna do the bonus show for our
members and our patrons and remember
that thanks to your support we now have
the staffing and resources that we can
rotate break so instead of everybody
just having to go on break at the same
time and the show is just dark for
periods including up to sometimes two
weeks of shows we still have production
staff when I'm away and then I come back
and we have rotating production staff
and we can afford to bring in the guest
host so this is
all because of your support over the
last I guess over the last year and a
half to two years we've really really
been able to ramp this up so thank you
consider participating in that funding
of progressive independent media by
grabbing a membership at join pakman.com
or by pledging even as little as a
dollar or two on patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show let me know on
Twitter at D Pakman or at david pakman
show number one how do benin Ferren due
next week and number two who else would
you like to see guest hosting the David
Pakman show
and they've got to be more or less in
line with my politics I think to be good
fits for the show let me know we've
still got all of today we will take
phone calls I will answer audience
questions we've got a great bonus show
coming up but next week the show has not
been cancelled and I have not been
kicked off of the show I'm just gonna be
off for four days and then I'll be back